okay there's this Argentinian guy named
Adolfo Cambiaso many call him the goat
of polo you know the sport with the
horses and the sticks and the ball and
all the money like the logo on your
collared shirt Adolfo has been ranked
among the world's best polo players for
22 years straight so random question
what is this goat of polo have to do
with a businessman named Alan and his
pancreas that actually leads to a pretty
crazy story about how clones are
transforming sports and your life but
maybe not yet but soon so let's take a
deeper look at how the polo goat and the
pancreas are linked let's start from the
beginning meet Alan Meeker he's a
businessman Texas through and through
and he loves horses but like 30 million
Americans he's got diabetes clearly
being a financier in aw
Meeker had a few extra and unusual
resources at his disposal and he started
researching whether cloning his pancreas
could cure diabetes and it could have
changed lives but alas the clone
pancreas was a no-go
but Meeker learned a lot and he became
an amateur cloning expert fascinated by
what it could do for polo so we set up a
cloning company in Texas
Meeker license the technology that had
been cloning all kinds of mammals since
1996 including the famous sheep names
Dolly
Sammy Kerr figured it wouldn't be much
of a stretch to clone horses too but he
wanted to work with the best DNA so he
flew all the way to Argentina the mecca
of polo when he got there Meeker met
with that Argentinian guy we talked
about earlier you know the goat Adolfo
Adolfo's prized horse died almost ten
years earlier after an injury in a
championship match ever the
forward-thinking goats Adolfo saved his
horses DNA and Meeker had to have it
together the two set out to clone and
read a horse army
just kidding scratch that together the
to set out to clone and breed the best
herd of polo horses on planet earth and
revolutionized the game of polo hashtag
squad goals and clone they did Meeker
and the goat have created more than 25
clones of Cambiaso champion polo horses
and their company Crestview has cloned
more than 200 horses since 2009 some are
even breeding and miraculously in 2017 a
polo championship was won using the DNA
of those prized horses you heard that
right
that goat won the Argentine Open riding
only cloned horses so thanks to Alan
makers pancreatic problems and visionary
thinking you can now own a cloned horse
of your own for upwards of a cool 100
thousand US dollars but that's not the
whole story
for more watch new episodes of Explorer
on National Geographic
[Music]
[Music]